and at some point a very
big agency wrote Verona comes into the room
and sits down on the chair and says
the chair squeaks then she takes the
glass and says the glass and then I
said sorry, I do
n't speak like that and everyone was dead quiet, yes but
you have the image of a data protection,
I mean, but that's not funny, yes,
it's not funny, I do
n't say such funny things, you hear me
talking all the time, that was
n't any different than today and everyone is so
brooding, brooding because of that  The joke was
so big in Germany that I always
twisted something. It was the biggest joke there was
in Germany and the
agency wanted to develop a linguistic joke,
but I don't say the table
and I don't say the lamp either, so it was
written here  is helped and then
I said as an example,
little things happen to me e.g. they help me
something like that could slip out of me
welcome to the R podcast you are
actually I have almost seen
Verona from Hamburg so she is a guest in
the one episode that is much much too  It's
late because you should actually have gotten together a lot
early,
but you're still only
now our guest in your
almost hometown of Hamburg, so
welcome Verona hi Verona hi Philip,
actually we could have gotten together much earlier,
but you're
very busy  I'm very
busy and that was probably
the reason because when the invitation came
I didn't have to think for long, you
've already made a great name for yourself, you
're great with the guests, your
podcasts are super exciting and it's
just fun to be there and
By the way, I'm from Hamburg, I
grew up completely here but lived for over 35 years
even though I
've just turned 40. Don't laugh so loudly then you'll
notice why you're laughing and
I love the city and my home
here Hamburg and I'm here too  I
grew up going to school and I
know every square meter. Hamburg is
actually really my heart
when you talk about the city, but
why did you leave?
Fran came from London and at some
point said we could live in Düsseldorf
and that's where I did  said what should
we do in Düsseldorf? That seemed very small to me at the time
and I had no
connection to Düsseldorf and so it became Cologne
because I was hosting a late show for RTL at the time,
Verona's World, and the joke
was that I lived in the Mauritius Therme
in Cologne and my apartment my
apartment was one to one like the
studio of Verona's world so we
just bought everything twice so
I practically lived in my own
studio so we were able to do
a bit of filming and studio at my house
because everything looked the same  That was
my idea back then and they
actually implemented it so I came
to Cologne for two years through RTL. Fran moved the
love of her life from London directly to Cologne to live with
me and as soon as I was pregnant he
of course got the beautiful
Putz property, they really have one  Very
nice property in the Vogel
nature reserve in Meerbusch,
living in a monastery that is 300 years old
and as you can hear, you ca
n't beat it and then turned on the fireplace and had
the parquet floor
wiped down. I, with my
big pregnant belly, said I would
n't follow suit  Düsseldorf and then
I came to this
property and thought wow,
I don't want to leave here anymore and then we
lived there for 7 years, his family still lives
there, his brother with my
sister-in-law and the children, his mother,
his father is unfortunately the last one
passed away a year ago and now we have practically
moved around the corner, also in Meerbusch,
okay, okay, but let's start, that
means your career started in Hamburg,
but you have Bolivian roots, so
you were born there too, your parents
are Bolivians, say no, my
father is  German real Hamburger
Ernst Feldbusch so where is the
Bolivian name Feldbusch supposed to come from
Verona Feldbusch wasn't a
stage name so that sounds
very German to me and my
mother's name is actually Luisa karnincic
that doesn't sound Polivian either that's
why yes  They
no longer say Yugoslavian, but rather Serbian.
My grandpa Simon Kamenic came from
Serbia, my father Ernst Felkusch came
from Germany directly from
Hamburg, my mother Luisa, who
is half Bolivian and, to be more
precise, I'm a quarter Bolivian, oh
okay okay okay okay and  where does the
name Verona come from to conclude from
Italy because my Serbian grandpa met
my grandma on the border with Italy
from Verona and Verona
is not a first name okay okay so I am
the only Verona because in memory
of my grandma they called me Verona
and  So I'm eightfold, what do
you call it a mixed breed? Can you
still say that these days, but I say that I'm a
very successful
mixed breed myself, what happens to you early on? So
you're also kind of a
mixed breed, I know, but
at least I'm very blessed with different
talents  you once had a very
successful song, music career,
entrepreneurial career, you would almost
say an early influencer testimoni
career television presenter
what was the first thing that came and how
did it start for you
so the first thing was actually that I
worked as a model but that came about
Based on my size 178, I used to be
an extremely thin person by nature
and of course every photographer in Hamburg
spoke to me. I was only
15 and that was actually standard
for someone to come and say they had to take a
photo of you. Of course there were
a few of them too  there used to be
no network or a cell phone where
you could google a photographer. There
was just a guy standing in front of you who
was much older and said, would you come
to my house? I
opened the studio there, everyone in Fogra
has an old apartment because of that  Ceiling height,
the wallpaper was dripping down, that's what it means,
but have you
already earned any real money? No, you
first have to dare to go in there as a 15-year-old,
no, and then I
developed a concept that I never
went there without my best friend
and I had to  I learned very quickly between 16
and 17 how to interact with people and
I really learned that so quickly
because it was always about everything because
of course there were a lot of crazy people in between
and that was pretty dangerous so
I wouldn't allow my 15 year old daughter to
do that anymore
Something, yes, there was a situation where
of course the photographer
said at some point we can also take nude photos
of you, totally popular, of course, only
black and white pictures. You know the pictures
of Helmut Newton, which, by the way, every
photographer had hanging in their house in the early 90s
and you  I'm so young and I
always no because I'm very conservative
even if I don't look like it, but
it was always very, very tiring to
get out of it again but you
had to get your foot out the door,
no agency would have taken you without
test photos and  There was no cell phone and
even retouching and quick recordings
you had to go through it but then
in the end you trusted a photographer
and he took good photos
and then it started so that you were
then booked as a model or what have to be said,
no  There were a lot of
photographers, it was a long road and it
was a rocky road to even get
the prints until someone
kept his word. I always survived the millions of
discussions about taking off a t-shirt or
not, but
then at some point you had good
pictures  and then I worked in two
modeling agencies here in Hamburg and that's how
I earned my first money at the age of 16 or 17.
I was one of many models,
of course you don't get 4,5,6000
€ or German marks right away, but I
worked my way up and then  When I was 21, I
opened my fashion studio Always Beautiful Design and I had it
registered as a trademark name Always
Beautiful Design I was
21 and that was with our fashion is
always beautiful, my best friend Sonja
and I then
opened the fashion studio atrutschbahn 38  For 6 years
and at that time Alex Christensen, who
is still mega successful today, came
along and makes music. He was 20.
I was about 19 when we
met and we never had
anything together. He never
hit on me like you do  nice says but
he said your looks
absolutely match the music you can also sing
I really don't sing well but
my mother was thinking of my
South American mamita she always
said some things are only asked once in your
life then you first say yes
and then sort it out  you that after that and I
yes I can sing and so I came to the
legendary Studio 33 where Michael Jackson
Madonna with Luis Rodriguez everyone
had already recorded and a day like
today I had a microphone in front of my
mouth I was in a room with
headphones I could do that  You didn't
google it back then, you looked at it and you actually
learned it through social media. It was
really like the young one came to the child and
everyone behind the window gave me a
text
Producer Alex hoo
Ingo always mistyped it like that then I heard
the speeches and they thought I was
n't hearing that and then one of them said to the other yes
but it looks like a million that's
it for who else should we use that
's exactly the look for ritmo danche  and
the other one but she can't sing and
I heard everything and my talent was
to act as if I didn't hear it
and thought inside myself that I had to die and
then afterwards we shortened the text to
one sentence
and then I got a golden one
I got a record I was number 1
europaik got a five year contract with Eastwest Europe's
largest record company
then followed ritm notche
everybody Salsa olela Ola Fiesta
tropical and finally RISM flower
Beat so not only did I
have a summer song but I was
on tour for 3 years
For a contract like that, if you have a contract like that for 5 years,
it was already
millions of dollars. No, I was a very
small Miss Hamburg, I became that
on the side and was about to take part in the Miss
Germany pageant and my voice
was higher than it is today, the skirts were very, very
short  That was just
a different fashion back then. Fashion changes
too and I was 20. I came
to the studio every day like that. I didn't have
two looks. I had this short skirt
that I sewed myself because I had
a studio  had long hair, a
voice that was way too high and thin legs
and then they gave me a contract
that some really good singers
wait their whole lives for and I had like 30 pages on the table with
my voice and this one set song
and
then I did  took a really deep breath
and said I can somehow
ask a lawyer, I don't even know what's in there
and then one of
my producers, who was 30 at the time, pulled me
aside and said it doesn't matter what's in there
because it's an art
you have to hand it over if you do
n't like something you
just don't have to sing anymore you ca
n't be taken advantage of by us I wasn't
anyone that somehow made sense to me
and then I
signed and of course I
got money but I wasn't immediately
enough  I was also a
newcammer and then suddenly I was
on stages, I went on tour, I was
the first western group in Beijing on
TV, really, with
ritmodellanche, there are a lot of
stories too, but the Scorpions were once
my opening act in Singapore, your
opening act, yes, actually  They
sang and already dismantled and then
my tour manager said Colorado, his name was
actually the one who said the party
was so cool. They somehow
heard that you were here, so through him
they didn't know us in Singapore,
they would tell you and they  Pay the fee again
when you go on stage and
because everyone was partying so much, we
performed after the Scorpions and I always meet Klaus now,
you used to be mine from the
Scorpion, okay, but that means you've
already hinted at your
modeling career  You also ran,
then you were Miss Hamburg then Miss Germany and
world and then Miss World and Miss
American Dream and that was the pageant
that belongs to Don Trump, he personally
chose me ah yes yes, it's in my
book, luckily I have it too  a few
pictures you didn't have a cell phone back then
and he's completely
from Germany, so his grandparents are from Germany, they
're from Germany. He's now in the
third fourth generation,
but he was
of course very interested in Miss Germany,
you always have it like that  a reference like that and it
was said at the time he was just separating from
his wife Ivanka and we were 100
international misses they say they
were actually in his casino in
New York outside of New York, it was
in the Touch Mahal I think it was so
long ago and then  We were all
told that no one speaks to him and no one
gives him a telephone number. I was
light years away from
speaking to him or giving him a number,
but he was
very interested in Miss Germany,
understandably because he of course
has these ancestors and I was always there
next to me  thought god oh god
what are you doing now well but
of course he was polite and nice and it
was all a long time ago but
then I became you didn't find it attractive no
I don't think anyone finds that or do
you find him attractive no no no can
You can't say no, it was also
far too big a number and Donald Trump
America, it wasn't what
happened to me at all, but that's what a
lucrative career it is now,
going through these pageants, you do it
more because you have fun with it
Or was there somehow a
calculation behind it? Well, a calculation is too
harsh to put it, but actually
I always had a plan, of course no,
it's like that, it's a ticket like that
and you get there from one day to the
next, you travel around the world
I would never have been
able to afford that privately. My parents, my father was an
engineer, my mother had a
hairdressing salon, my parents were
divorced, I lived in Hamburg. We did
n't have a big house or
anything, we actually moved so often
and it was always at the limit
I was fine, but I
also had to struggle a bit, but that
was also the energy to become so successful
because I don't say I came
from the bottom and
worked my way up, but it was like that.
My parents loved me. My parents
were intelligent  They also
taught me how to behave and both were
very interesting people. My father was
typically German, the Hansiatic
engineer, he always had the best
ideas, he had a good sense of humor, a
bit like Harald Schmidt.
I always laughed a lot with them, he was very
tolerant and...  relaxed my dad my
mother looked like sopia Loren at
1.50 m tall I was actually in
tune and was such an insane
career woman I inherited all of that from her
and I always knew that if
you work a lot you can make a lot of
money  earn and brought my professions
together, so to speak, by
becoming Miss Germany,
I won a brand new car.
Hello, if I hadn't achieved in
light years what others
got for their Abitur, I would never have been
able to afford it and a ticket
for a year  To represent Miss Germany Germany
worldwide, I came
to Singapore to
Beijing to Africa to Turkey to
Greece in the 90s and flew around the world
in the best hands I could
and I was looked after very well,
so of course I traveled the world
and made my contacts in order to
then get ahead, because
at that time you also had a classic,
let's say, business administration
training, an apprenticeship, something
like that, no, it says in the media every now and then
from the early days that I
completed an apprenticeship as a tailor, that's
not true  my best friend who
was my partner at always beautiful
design, who had completed her tailoring teacher training, she
spelled it wrong once, sometimes it gets
picked out, no, that was the case for me. I
left school shortly after graduating from high school,
but also because of the
model career, no  Yes, not so not so
conveniently wasn't it? It was
actually like that. I worked a lot
and school was becoming more and
more in the background. My parents did
n't have the time because I didn't
come from such a perfect family where
everyone was over  everyone is talking at the kitchen table
and child, you have to go back to
school too, I was already very much on my own
for, let me say, during
the week and um I just realized
that I have a business sense and that
the world is waiting for me and school
moved further and further back and
then at some point the teacher
came up to me and said you have to
pull yourself together because otherwise
this won't work and don't waste your
talent and when I heard the word talent I thought I did
n't have any talent at all  school
and then I thought everyone says to
their child what is right somewhere,
first you finish your studies
and then you can like to become an artist,
because then you have a background
and I thought I would
n't finish school now  End and what happens
if you don't have a background then
your back is against the wall and from that
day on I knew that it wouldn't be good for
me if I didn't
become successful without a degree and then
of course I turned one day into two and
actually  Just working and working all the time
means model music, um, um,
then also the studio, so
you also did the tailoring yourself. You
told me in the preliminary conversation that you had pre-tailored numerous dresses yourself for
this Miss World
contest in New York
so that
several large suitcases would travel there and
not then  to put them all on myself
but to sell them so
what's funny today my suitcase did
n't arrive as a little advance anecdote and
all my shoes aren't there
now I was in the Alsterhaus
especially for you this morning and bought myself some nice
Valentinos yes ngelnag  new but
what just went through my heart was in the
Alsterhaus before it was so stylishly renovated.
I spent my whole
youth there in the
fabric department and bought all the fabrics for
my clothes in the Alsterhaus.
I was actually with my blonde friend every day
An older saleswoman was still doing it
in the Alzerhaus short-distance department buttons
border sequins fabrics 150 wide 2 m
wide they were still measured with a
long wooden stick with the
big scissors I remember this
noise R rck cut off cheap
was 15 € naturally went up to 120  €
up and we put all the money we
earned into these fabrics, the
seams from them, dresses, unique pieces with
always beautiful designs and a lot of savings
and then when I became Miss Hamburg
and was allowed to go to Miss Universe in Mexico,
I said to Sonja we'll do
one  Evening wear collection with
our money, everything we have, all
tailored to my figure but we can't
afford anything else and
I'm going to Miss Universe with all the clothes
and then we have all our
money, what we had, which of
course wasn't that much because you have to  Yes,
imagine the studio is
still there today rutschban 38 We also lived
there to save on the second rent, so
we lived again in the trash at
our work and sewed day and night
until the collection
was finished then I flew out and
everyone  Day when you sit at a table in the evening with 100
girls from all
nationalities you know how beautiful it is you
look to the right Miss gana Miss
Holland Miss tobego Miss Columbia miss
WE is so beautiful and everyone is always wow what are
you wearing and I just have everything  Worn
once and then in my
little room we were always
put up two to a room and then
she came and knocked and bought the
things from me and I already
set up a deal and sold the whole
collection and they had the
right money and they  wanted these
dresses from Germany at any price,
they were also unique pieces and came
back with all the money and
Sonja and I were
of course really happy at the time when we were 21-22 and I
said now we have to go to the media about
our collection, we have it
first story I
sold my first collection at Miss Universe
Mexico and then ST that was everywhere in the
newspapers Miss tausensass she sings she
tailors and she is still Miss Germany
and I don't know what she
wrote but that was a breakthrough, at
least as I remember it
Then you're more likely to be on TV or I
mean than the whole country of
Germany is from you, but then you were
more of a TV presenter or
Miss Hamburg and Miss Germany, which
was here in Hamburg, I had
a headline every week, you thought
so  always I would have an affair with
the picture newspaper with the evening paper with the
morning post with everyone because I
was cute in the eyes I was 21
had a beautiful girlfriend the
media thought we were cute I would
too today and they were our friends at the
time that should be  change at some point
but at the moment I was like
a puppy protector, they said look at the
little one, the other day she was Miss
Hamburg oh now she's Miss Germany
and then now she too and yes
and the headlines were every day
that everyone  My private friends already
say how do you do that and then came a
program like schreinemarker Stefan Rab
or Hans Meiser Ilona Christensen,
none of which are available in
the V today, and then my only thing
that I see was my greatest talent, that was
that  talk but no one knew they
invited me we have
a little one here today with Germany and he
even has her dress yes and then I came in
yes then the speaking talent came and after that
it was immediately like wow next week
we want another show  you didn't
come and I was
passed through all the talkchs in
Germany and that was the breakthrough, so to speak,
that I started to
be known all over Germany,
of course I was in Hamburg and you were
quickly offered your own show.
No, then it came
We don't have to mention the big bang of anything very
briefly, Bohlen, so at that
time he came into my life. To put it briefly,
we were friends for a year
without being together, not
married, not engaged and not a
couple that year either  he married me 346,000
times I wanted to marry him I said
NO 364,000 times then I
said yes we flew to Las Vegas we
got married
nobody noticed because we
didn't want to and didn't tell anyone
and then  we came back and Harald
Schmidt summed it up so beautifully.
After four weeks we had
drifted apart and there was a
bang because we didn't have a contract.
Dieter was Dieter, he was 42. I'll emphasize
this again here, he was
42  you know how young that actually
is for a man. I was somehow 37,
I think, and at the time it happened, he was 37 at the time,
then I was 27. I'm not
that good with the numbers, but he was 42.
I still remember that and then we have
Due to the divorce,
this big thing actually happened and then
of course I was immediately
known all over Germany because it was almost like a soap,
but now no joke, he
too, he was suddenly back at Betting
that with Thomas Anders, there was a comeb
and also so  an incredibly lucrative
divorce for both of you, yes and many
say you became known through him, no
through the divorce and I
filed for it and both of us. He was
already mega successful before, without question,
but it had been quiet around him for 10 years,
that is  Yes, it's not a bad thing,
so I hope it's not indiscreet, but
how do you get to know each other in Hamburg? I
'm also a resident here now, so it
's just a coincidence. Actually, he
never left back then because I was traveling a lot here
in Hamburg. I never
met him and then one  The only day
he told me later that it was
my exception that he went away, that was
in Tracks, we got to know each other very briefly
and his first sentence was
hey, stop there, I would like to
marry you, it was of course also fun and I
just said back  I don't have any time at the moment
and disappeared into the crowd and
it actually started like that,
but what a great little thing, I
couldn't tell you that today and
he wrote it himself in his own
book, but so much for
your question because  A lot of people
just think that's how I
became known. No, I had already
competed on various TV shows, I had vi
international beauty titles, I had
a gold record,
I produced a total of six songs, I had my
fashion studio and through the record company
Iswest, I of course worked for Kye Minuk
and many others  Your videos,
the kleiderdig because the record company
have my designed dresses that I
wore on stage, they were of course
cool, they weren't just photographed evening dresses
and always have them, it's
crazy, they're all tailor-made.
I had the idea of ​​buying patent fabric at the time,
but not a lot of patent  and
leather but the fashion like jeans only made of
patent leather, wide seams like
denim jackets with flowers on them and so
on and that didn't exist back then
and then the first inquiries came. K
minok is also with us at the
record company she is looking for a trenchkut
for a video we didn't fit it for
her size and so I don't think it's an issue, we
have a fashion studio and suddenly
I had newspaper articles about how I, as a
designer for big
names, designed clothes, I still remember
Klaus and Klaus was a huge topic at the time,
folk music, yes, it was as big as  Helene
Fischer and we
made leather pants like dürndel for the girls for
the background but really cool ones,
you know, Tyrolean pants made of red patent leather with
frilly little flowers, always very
playful and sweet but all made of patent leather
and for Klaus and Klaus they already have
one  The width of the wall that you played on there was
from Kin to Klaus and Klaus and so on back
then, of course, so that we suddenly had a lot of
celebrities in our small
studio thanks to the record company,
but then it must have gone so well.
I read an interview
with you before  Some time ago, I
think at Capital where you talked about your first
million and
at least that's what you told me, I think when you were
27 or something like that, so it was around
that time that all these
things were worth it for you,
so to be more precise it was  my 29th
birthday when my bank
called me and asked me what
I would do with the money now
and I was completely amazed and
thought three times what does seven figures mean
and the magazine
capital has had this series for years
my first million and
a lot of cool people have already
given interviews, it's always a
strange feeling to talk about money,
but I had read through some interviews of
mega-successful entrepreneurs,
among others,
Philip Pling was in this interview at the time,
but there are  Yes,
endlessly great entrepreneurs then I
thought okay, I'm about
90 now in this series then I'll
talk about that too because you're always
kind of trained not
to talk about money but I'm
probably because of all my
advertising contracts  It's no longer a secret anyway and
on the other hand I thought I
actually did it all on my own
and on my 29th birthday I got
a call from my bank to find out
how we should invest my money and that's where
my
image comes from  I knew
that I was already earning well, but to be
honest, there's no
money coming out of the bank anyway, why should I
call every day, then
ask again when I have time
to take care of my finances and suddenly
they called me,
congratulations  It's my birthday on April 30th,
yes, dear Ms. Fellpus, no, we
now have a seven-figure amount and
I haven't even thought about
what that means. They should
think about how they want to invest it. I think I'll
do it and then
I hung up and said  to Sonja, why is
the bank calling me now? Back then
it was still the Deutsche Bank,
um, and then I said why are they calling
me and then she means what do
you mean by seven digits and I do
n't know, she means they just
congratulated you  that you're a millionaire,
okay, okay, and I don't come from
a wealthy family,
I actually had nice parents, and
more importantly,
intelligent ones with style, and they
raised me well, but we
never had much money because of the divorce
no and yes but still I
went on every school trip I also
got a bike for my birthday but
we never had so much money that you
could buy a Golf when you graduated from high school like in
the 90s or just say
go on vacation I am  always to
Mallorca with this coach with my
friends, we all saved up for it for a
whole year and
went to Mallorca with a coach like that, that doesn't exist
anymore, oh God, you said it, yes,
somehow you can for 10 € a night
you can imagine but I've also
learned a lot at the moment, but of
course the call was right and then
you started, um, I also read about
investing in real estate, yes,
because it was clear to me that I was never, I
never wanted to be such a gambler and  be a financial fox
and make myself important and
always look at the stocks every day.
I'm very conservative, so it's
sometimes deceiving at first glance. I've
never been in Playboy. That says
a lot. I'm more conservative than I
look and am  But I also made
it easy with the finances.
I always
bought properties in good locations and
then the money turned to stone and
I didn't have to worry about it
either. I lived there or
rented it out and I wasn't that lucky either
and how many properties have there
been today? Thousands of thousands. The whole of Hamburg
belongs to me. I'll be on the bill soon.
No, I simply bought properties with the money
I had. They were
properties in good locations that I
could easily finance with my money and
then pay them off at some point  and
then the money was first of all a security
then I could continue working again
and buy a property again
but we're already talking about 20 or 30 of
them these days no, so
I can really tell you the number, I could
probably concentrate on it again now
but I have  Yes,
sometimes I sold two or three apartments
and bought something larger.
I then continued to
invest it in Hamburg, but everything
or now in Cologne, in
Hamburg and also in Düsseldorf and for
me that was of course a measure
that even the bank  Back then, do
you know what Ms.
fbusch said to me? So you are the only
customer who didn't lose €1 this year,
you didn't invest anything at all
and I said yes, I
'm not that greedy, I do
n't always have to go out back then  Make another DMark out of
a DMark 2 if the interest
is no longer allowed at the moment but
still, but worked hard, there were
times when you somehow
had ten advertising contracts at the same time or something like that and then you
somehow had to be available day and night
stand for shootings and stuff like
that, of course that was the time when the media
named me an advertising icon because
I can't
give myself that title and I always think it's so sweet
Now it's called Pot, I think it's
great anyway that she
took her husband's name. Nowadays
no one does anything wrong anymore, but
I still say my brand is and yes, but
no one gives a name like that, but they
're great, they stand by it  her husband
but you know what who is the
Kaiser and I Franz Beckenbauer and
then I mean like that and then he said who is
the pop titan and I tierboh yes and
who is the advertising icon and then
I mean ah in the men's world I have a
nickname where  I would be
written down in every crossword puzzle
and I thought that was pretty cool because that's what
he wanted to tell me. It was like 70
or more that only three
personalities managed
to have such a nickname as an advertising icon,
no, but who is that when someone says it to you
today  Who was the emperor? You
always just come up with a question: Who is the
pop titan? You don't have to think about who
is the advertising icon and he explained that to me
so beautifully at the time. My he and all the
other names need an explanation. There was a
time when it was actually you  the
first big influencer without there being
Instagram or YouTube or
something like that,
but that means you were
always in the campaigns in the end and
then enjoyed or used the reach
that these companies bought from
classic media and you were
part of them  the the the spots or the the
the photos there are these blub
stories and so spinach so h
just took everything or did you
choose or did you think about how do
I do that or how did that come about who
managed you there yes so I had
Of course, at the time before I
signed my first advertising contracts,
we were at the beginning of the 90s, which lasted
through the entire 90s and into the 2000s.
Advertising wasn't that desirable either, so
footballers who advertised anti-dandruff shampoo
got a lot of money,
but they did  You couldn't see any joy on your face,
it was always a bit like
a punishment, no, no one wanted to
advertise a dishwasher
for some information number for
car tires, you just didn't want that,
but you got seven-figure sums
every time, no, everyone, it was just
a royal class  in in the area of
earnings but you just didn't want to
sell dandruff shampoo as a cool footballer and
then I got my first advertising contracts and
it wasn't easy either
helped before I
invented the slogan,
it was an information number that
couldn't be drier and, um, and
I had to conjure something up with it first
and then it became cult and
funny and nice and it's even in the
German Duden but the idea for it  That's
how they get help, so to speak,
that was your idea because I've
only worked with the most renowned advertising agencies
in Germany,
most of them still know me, they
've already written very good sports,
they were always in the pitch and it was all
about that  really money so I
always wondered when the guys back then
between 35 and 40 came to the meeting with their three days
already slightly shaking
and I said hello again, where is
everyone then I saw them pre-sounding the whole thing for
this spot, the best
agency here  in Germany they had to
present them to me and
I didn't even know that there were
two competitors in the room then
I always said I think it's good
I don't think it's good and that and that and
at some point a really big
agency wrote to Verona  into the room and
sits down on the chair and says the
chair squeaks then she takes the glass
and says the glass and then I said
sorry, I do
n't speak like that and all dead silence yes but
you have the image of a weakness
I mean  But that's not funny, yes,
it's not funny. I do
n't say such funny things. You hear me
talking all the time, it was never any
different than it is today and everyone is so pondering,
pondering because the joke was
so big in Germany that I  always twisting something a bit,
that was the biggest joke there was
in Germany and the agency
wanted to develop a linguistic joke but
I don't say that table
and I don't say the lamp either so it
said here he will be helped and then
I said  As an example,
little things happen to me, e.g. they help you,
something like that could slip out, then
everyone laughed, I think for half an
hour and then the production manager said
quiet please, we have to get a little
serious now and look for something funny, I
mean, wait a minute, we've just got it
everyone laughed spontaneously, we are
all creative and laugh until the
beams bend. We found it.
They will be helped
and everyone will be helped. They will be
helped. They will be helped.
Nobody even knew what it was
called anymore and that's how it came about  The slogan
also made you Dasch a millionaire,
so a sport like that in the end, it
's also lucrative then yes you
have to pay taxes in Germany too,
I'm the same way with I do
n't want 50% but I've always been
far  over 40 ne if I earned 500 €
I could hand over 250 straight away,
you shouldn't forget
that I was in the highest tax bracket
and on the other hand, of course,
I created the sport
in such a way that it was so funny
that Z's contracts  were extended to five years ago
and the phenomenon
was that I had about 10 at the same time,
that's never happened again.
Overall, I think I have
spinach, no, I don't know anymore, wait,
yes, it was 11880 then it was Iglo the
blub then  It was still black then
in the early days I had the
car brand deu, that's what I actually
started with then the Smart came along with
the show Verona what was it called V
Formula 1 Formula One I
reported on Formula 1 so to speak and
but  I had a contract with the
Smart, which then ran with
bkenstock, I had a contract but I
can't remember JVC anymore. At
the same time, JVC was still running at the same time. The electrical
devices were very, very
large back then, Schwarzkopf Schwarzkop, were you
surprised or was that easy for you
everything so they get in touch
we do it or or was there somehow there was
a selection or or did you
say man it's great I'm
happy the more comes D you better
my work was actually to always
build a connection to the product that
has to do with it  They didn't calculate that I
could do that at 11880 there was only one
reason why he took me, the DR
Harisch der Liebe Klaus, who
founded it back then, didn't even know me
and then he said to his team
why should we take Verona felpusch now
too  When it
's so popular at the moment, only men call,
not a single woman in Germany will
dial 11 880 because they see her as a
competitor because she
's dressed too sexy, that doesn't work, and then
the results were always that
I was 60 with women  % popular and with
men 40 despite my
appearance at the time that was why I
was so suitable for advertising and today on my
Instagram when I go to my insights
I can show you later
it's like this again 60% women and 40 men
because you have a sexy one  Looks like it could
be that you read 90 for men
and ten for women then you ca
n't sell a curling iron, you have to
operate the site then you can
sell car tires, you're
really popular with women and no man
clicks on you, you have both
Target groups so men and women
brought together, so to speak, both of them
were the distribution and there and
back then they did this distribution for a
lot of money, every single company
I worked with
did this distribution and that's where it came
out and that was the secret  why I'm
almost for every product and why how do
you explain that simply because women
also somehow saw themselves in you or I
think because I like women a lot so
sexually speaking I'm only into
men but I think women are beautiful
people and great people and  I'm
a type of girl, there are also
beautiful women on my Instagram 1us.
I also like being with beautiful women.
I'm not that
stubborn, I'm not a loner and
I love beautiful women and also young,
great women when they come and sit and set the
mood  always at my
table people of the same age and my best
friends who are completely with me
and you that hot you want to say in the
end women have always been important to you
and they notice that so now I'm
on tour and when I'm on
stage  What do I do, invite Lisa
Feller? Tomorrow I'll be in the
Schmidtchen, so I'll be in the theater in the
Schmidtchen and I have to say I'll be performing
with Lisa Feller then I'll be
out with Rut Moschner in Vienna. I
called my very old friend Arabella Kiesbauer because she  also Bauer
sucht Frau Austria has been moderating for 10 years and
no one cancels on me, so
women like you and that has
always helped you, and you may radiate something like that, of
course you can
say something like that, but it's not mine and of
course you notice it very quickly with women
who are successful and maybe also
look quite good are the girl
girls there is always a group of
women together and we support
each other female empowerman is really
a topic and
I really have a lot of women around me
and I would recommend them all to support
and strongly  make and
pass on my contacts because it's like the thing
with the smile you smile at
you will definitely get one in
return and I'm not all mine
and I don't want a second woman
near me and the audience notices that back then,
the viewers today  Followers notice
that when is when or how did
it subside then so today you do
n't have ten
advertising contracts at the same time anymore so
you didn't decide at some point
I don't want to do that anymore in that
dimension or did you at
some point  Or was there
no longer such a demand for you as it was? No,
it's not a job, it's just
not a job because in kindergarten
they want to be a firefighter,
become a hairdresser or a doctor. Nobody says I'm
going to be an advertising icon. Actually, you have to
get the gold medal first and then
You get advertising contracts, so advertising
refers to successful people
because you want to use their followership
and that is the new profession of
influencers, it is an inflation but
the really good ones
also earn very good money and work
very hard at it around the clock,
of course they claim  that everyone of themselves
and I have to smile a little
bit but the we I good top
10 are also really great financially and of
course but for you it would
actually be or or would you or yes
I just want to understand the journey
then it has  At some point I gave a demolition,
I still do less and after
all those years in the noughties and
90s when everything was going well,
it was fine until 2000 anyway, no, I
had the whole time warming up,
I just said that there was a piee
But there always has to be a piee,
even in our podcast if you
do it, it will hit the highest in a minute, for whatever reason,
and
then it can only go up and down to the right and left,
but it's not a
job and of course you can't say
mine  I've had ten advertising agents throughout my life,
it would be nice, I'm very creative,
my ideas don't stop, I've just got
a new
advertising partner right now, just as you're talking about it
I'm 12 and I'm in front of
the camera together and in January
they're going to be on TV so you ca
n't say why yet, no, of course
not because they want to take the hype with them,
but it was a lot of fun
and I'm also a testimonial
for Pacific  healc from my
cosmetic line I think you answered
me well I would have expected you to
say hey I
started to move away from being in front of the camera
and became more of an entrepreneur
because you still have a clothing brand
so Verona was Verona's dreams yes Verona's
dreams  Also, I
was actually still
incredibly young back then, that was the answer to
Victoria Secret, because it doesn't
really exist, Victoria is a killer brand,
a killer brand worldwide, of course, in
America in DUS and I
did DUS here in Germany in 118 branches
I started shop and shop at Karstadt.
Back then we didn't know
what that meant. I had to ask three times
what it meant
and then I had already made the disus for cirvy Model
at the time the WT was
created and
if you google
it now you can still see it in my presentation.
Up to 2000 people came to such a branch
when I presented the disus
I had already invited the first curvy models
and that was a huge
eye-catcher, of course
not just curvys, but I was also
a pioneer and that was the German
answer to Victoria Secret but that is
a bit toned down in
the same form as  Karstad
has also become less relevant in the world, no,
that came later with Karstad, you
just can't do everything,
I'm very versatile and at the
same time I had a
jewelry collection from Verona Streams, which
was also sold in Karstadt but
also at jewelers  was silver jewelry
and a cooperation with SOS
Children's Villages where I
had built my own children's village for 112
children and when I had a small
book signing we had to
block off the streets so the pictures
exist, yes I can't make it
all up but I could
n't keep everything up either  I
did that for 5 years and then
did something new again. From DUS I went
into jewelry, then it was homeware jogging suits,
so I always
felt drawn to do something new,
which you can now read about
your current company  With your
husband you have Pacific healthcare, that
describes it, it gives you
some kind of skin cream now, yes, that's it, they
are caring products and I have to
say that the career that I just
described was of course my
career too, I started at a young age
at 20 and of course
someone at 20 is different than at
30 40 50 60 I think these periods are
crucial in life because a person
at 20 should be like 20 but will
never be able to think like someone at 40 in the way
you can't think today  like
someone at 60 and at this time
you're doing your own things with this boy
and when things were going so well
I just looked at it and said that's where
my image came from
But I don't want to reach the pie here with your jewelry
and I had another
idea again, of course everyone was floored when
I left the room and
said Kleene, she has a
shot but that's what happened so that's
how I was  It was the voice, it was
the looks and then who knows
successful things but someone who is 20
thinks it never ends at 30 you have
a different head at 40 at 50 but
now I'm an adult I've
done it I'm an adult and Frano
was  yes, not like me Fran is an
entrepreneur through and through he loves brands he is
so branded he loves brands
to produce brands whether it's mineral water
whether it's spanks the hot
underwear who in the bodice department or
whether it's cosmetics he has such an eye
for brands and he said in California
Verona CBD is an ingredient
that is extracted from the hand plant
and that is the side that doesn't make you high
but the one that also makes you home, that is the one that
is used in medical products and that was
the law in California  had
changed CBD was open to the cosmetics market
and he didn't know anything about anything
else. He said yes. If you're a
thoroughbred company, you have to
invite him and then he says Veruna, I don't care if you're angry with
me or not
Brand big in Germany with CBD
ingredient We will
also get this approval in Germany in a few weeks
for the ingredient I'll do it
then and I only
noticed in one that I
had bought very expensive, high
quality cosmetics and for the first time I say
on the product the hand plant it was
a strange feeling the products were
great it has this ingredient is just
simple that was from his no no
that was there was still with the idea
when the name was founded that was in
California and I have  yes, you also said
you're really right, this plant is
highly healing, and then he
founded this company, brought in investors
and now the company has
grown incredibly in the third year and
I have to be honest and say that it definitely has
the chance to have
one across Europe  To become a strong brand you
only sell directly you do
n't sell a retailer but you sell
D2C direct to consumer via the
website D2C is the whole program
behind it because times
have changed there are no more shop in shop
we have of course also
placed something in  bruninger in Düsseldorf
because we come from Düsseldorf that
was also very nice to see with the
huge counterfight from me and a lot of
people were interested in it
but he has no chance against the digital
world and now coincidence comes,
nothing is so bad that it is for  What
else is not good? The pandemic has
of course also had an impact, so
women under 50 have mastered social media
so well on the internet that they can also
go shopping digitally and
women 50 and over also want to experience the tactile experience. They
want to go to Douglas to Kaufoff
to kstad  I don't know, go to the KDW
and touch the goods, talk about it, get
samples taken
back home with the bag, maybe drink a
cappuccino with your girlfriend in the city,
but during the pandemic,
decorative cosmetics, mascara, lipstick,
make-up were of course pushed aside like
never before  Because you could
n't put on make-up through the mask, you sweated behind it,
the lipstick was of course
the minute it was off, then you had a
white surface when you used make-up
and the breath, if you remember,
always went on your
eyelashes. People who wear glasses remember  Also
good, it was the first time that the
mascara, one of the most popular
products, stuck on the shelf like a stone,
so what did everyone want to continue to
be beautiful and take care of themselves right now? They all went for care
products and no one could
go shopping, so everyone did  50 plus mothers and
women said to their children, come
here quickly, how does it work here, it
's actually easy, they
've learned it and you know what,
if you go to Pacific Hellsker today
and choose a day cream,
it's in front of you  then
of course the digital world
automatically offers you a discount and says 30%
for this if you buy this on top of that
you buy two welcome to our
family sign up above then
you get this and that and of course you have
a profit at the end of 30
You made 40% a little too
much, who gets it, your best friend,
but you have this digital world that
has arrived at 50 plus like
never before the E company is aimed primarily
at 50 plus customers no from 25 no I
say that  25 year olds who only order
online okay but okay that's hot desw that
's learned that's what I want to say we
won 50 plus women who did
n't shop digitally before,
your mother doesn't know if you
imagine her now she drove into the city
said  I buy a few shoes
and when I exchange them it does
n't matter to me, that was also an experience, yes, but
today there are also 50 and 60 year olds who say that they
just order it and it's
basically sold in Germany or or in the
USA no Germany Austria and
Switzerland and how big is it  The company is
already selling goods
worth several million for it, so I
have to be honest and say Fran is the
founder and CEO of the company and he is the
full-blooded entrepreneur behind it. I am the
testimonial of course because I will
never forget the sentence like he did  I told myself
I would be stupid if I had the
hottest testimonies were his words in the
house because you are 50 plus and your
greatest asset in terms of your appearance is
your skin, that's what everyone who meets you says,
so you're a man now but you
see me now  In front of you, that's
my face and my neck, my cleavage,
you can't do everything with Botox, you ca
n't start with your calves, your
butt, your hands, you see me
now in front of you and then he says that
's it  Topic for you and I as a
total cream freak but that's
been my whole life, of course my
eyes have lit up,
so I mean if anyone on this
planet knows about cream it's me
and that's how we came together
so you can get the exact numbers
Of course, we're not
here to sell the guy for
you, but if you invite him over, it'll
definitely be exciting, but we
've grown really quickly now
and we have such a large range of
repeat buyers, which means they
trusted me, but they
I've seen social media channels that aren't
that big yet, so I thought okay, let's
see how big the
Instagram channels are now, there are
now 100,000 followers, they do
n't exist yet, no, so we're actually counting on that
not the
circle from where it is sold, it
works excellently but you
also have to keep in mind that as long as CBD
is an ingredient, it is also
not approved in certain regions in the digital world,
so there are still a few small
barriers but, um, before  I'm
also saying something wrong, no, this whole
company that really has Fran in
his hands. I have to be honest and
say that it's also his company, I say it
so consciously, but my line because
my know-how of 30 years when it
comes to creams and the complexion of my skin  Simply from
head to toe suggests that I have
done something right and high-
quality care products achieve
their goal if you use them long-term
and that was perhaps also
my luck that I have always loved it so much,
the cream,
you have also written a book
and  then of course I have to smile when
I read the title
super MILF so the more often you say
that the easier it is for
you so that
means what is the idea behind
bringing such a provocative title to the market well but look super means
super  Now we come to
MILF, that means in the middle of life, woman, that
's the one-to-one translation, you do
n't need a lot of imagination,
it's like, I have a different
translation, yes, the English one, but we
're in Germany, which is super in the middle of it
lebenfrau where there isn't
a bit of a twist on it either but that
means you just feel like writing a book,
well it's my fourth book and
after all I'm a Spiegel bestseller
and I have to mention that again briefly here.
We're talking about careers
Autobiography take everything and
give a lot maybe it fits even if you
listen to me here for a long time I have
already written a bestseller a
Spiegel bestseller and this is now
my fourth book there was once a
pregnancy book the little fbusch
there was once the BL but you do these  So
books too, so in the end there are
also books that you now
write yourself or with no, I
always have a ghost rider at my side
because I'm a talker and
writing, I'll say it's fun, of course
I can read and write but I
I'm actually exactly what's
happening here. You have a lot of guests on the
podcast, but you also notice that I
'm not at a loss for an answer. There do
n't necessarily have to be gaps
and of course I can give my
book the super MILF a
ten point guide as a guide  Plan for how you get through the
middle of life and it's brilliantly
written and therefore brilliantly
spoken because I do
n't want to stop my emotions when I
write and slow something down and so of
course there were thousands of tapes
and conversations and I
also said I have  a group of women around
me but the origin and also the
content comes from my head my
life experience because in the middle of life,
which starts around 40 and 50,
people just change like that,
both men and women but I
concentrated on women
and both  as biological but also from the
head,
for example, I have never been as grown up as I am
today and today I ask myself the question,
what do you actually want with your
second half? As
we know, there is no third half, so I know that I
only have one half left because we
humans know  yes, everyone, it's
finally life, yes and before I
never lived in the day but it seemed to me so
finally so endless I mean
and and and today I'm aware of it
and I want quality time I
only take jobs and appointments  Just like
with you, where I'm looking forward to
quality, yes, quality, cool
conversations, intelligent conversations, I
want to make products that, like my book,
are not just a funny play on words but content, but you don't have
the goal of making money at the end
Earn as nice as that sounds or is it
somehow for you but I mean I
actually don't care anymore now well of course
it never really matters
anyway otherwise everyone who
has earned well would quit. I was just
with Philip Plein at his
book presentation of the belief  I'm the
first one who could stop but he turns
one day into three so I
also work very hard. No,
money isn't the pure motivation, it
's a combination but for me
it's natural that I say in
life I want quality
Frano
I want to have quality with my children
I just don't want to spend any more
time with people who I say
I find useless so I don't think
they're useful to me but with I say
in German I don't need idiots
anymore I don't need lousy Peter
I don't need any more dissatisfied people
anymore. In my job,
the media always
blackmailed me so much if you don't say that now
and don't give the interview and then
this happens and that doesn't matter to me, it
all bothers me  I
'm more self-confident than ever and
self-confidence has never been lacking for me,
so you can imagine
what point I'm at right now and they
're cool, they're nice, they
also want to make a difference in the social area. I was
just in Thuringia at the children's home in
Gota and I have that  Brought gifts to the children,
that was very sad. The children came
from very difficult German
backgrounds, some of them were
taken in from the psychiatric hospital. It was
n't a nice day, but it still
filled my heart. That's
quality time for me, you know, and
I don't say no to things like that  because they move my heart
and when I come home
and rocolitum show the little videos on
my cell phone and say look little
mouse and tell mommy what they
were happy about the knick-knacks
you brought with you then
I think that's just the way it is  and that I
am also a role model for my
family and for my children and Diego at
20 who is 19.4 is currently trying to
become a professional golfer, I emphasize again, he has a handicap of zero, he plays
there and he also says mom, so me
am type you are my mother who is always
dressed in colorful clothes is a special case but
a real role model I
never see you sleep I only ever see you
working you are into you manage
the family you run you do you do
so you don't know me on that  Eating sofa chips
or something like that I think on Sunday
maybe an hour mhm he only
ever sees me yeah um but do you have that
when you see this this work set like that
and do you say somehow your
career is attention somewhere
also m it has already happened  A lot has also
changed and actually,
if you look at where you come from on
Instagram and so on, you could have been much bigger
than you are there now, so if
that had been your wish, you
were there
when the platform started, you
already had the fame  and the reach in
the classic world, you
sometimes accuse yourself of missing out on being even more
active on these social media platforms and
being there even earlier, so I would miss out on
600, I think 33,000 because I'm so funny
about 33  I'm
not missing out on anything, I'm revitalizing it
over time and I post
everything myself, of course I also have
two people when we produce fashion content,
of course, with whom we
shoot together. You can see that
in the quality, but I  I'm with
a whole team where he
's almost 25 35 and we create content
and we work together and that's
a lot of fun, which would be completely wrong to
get out of it, it's just that
an influencer translates into a
role model role  RLE mododel is
a role model and an opinion leader and
I've certainly been that for
many years. You'll see that
again at supermil. I'm on a
reading tour, the women come there and I
can't decide in advance
when I'm on stage  how old
is the average today and you
just see young girls who say hey
I want to be a great MILF too how
many tours do you do how many
tour stops do yes I am now in a
total of 13 I have 13 contact points
I will be in big theaters
I'm playing in the Pfefferberg Theater now, for example,
on the riberbahn in Schmidtchen and I
'm also in Hamburg in Leipzig, I do
n't know, in Berlin and only the
boys of 25 buy the book and say,
I'll be a great MILF too, then
you'll see others of the same age  40 50 they say
that's so cool simply because you know you
also have to consider these foods
you are suddenly 50 plus the parents die
the children move out you look
at your wife you have a marriage of 25
maybe 20 years behind you you
love  But the question is like a
sister or really like a
partner, what you have done up to now,
even if you have earned well, the
last thing you want to do is to
get really older, maybe
you don't want to
live in a completely different country or start in a completely
different profession and do
you want
the questions that come
to you in the middle of life in the night,
you don't have to call them and they make
it so that you don't sleep, you are
completely different from what you used to do  you
think about it a lot more, it's also
a phenomenon among women and it
also leads to unrest and there were
other answers that
you came up with apart from you want
more quality time, which is what you're currently saying
So too,
this real awareness that
life isn't just forever.
I never thought about that before. I
knew as a child that I would have to
die one day, but that was never present.
Today you just think, wow, time
goes by really quickly, you realize that  You're
older here too, you WST you say this sentence more often
you h what's been around this month again,
Christmas again, New Year's Eve
again and of course you
also want to do justice to your family.
Rocco is 12, he's as cute as a
pet is my hobby  and I
actually want to have him around me every day.
He's so funny and so sweet.
By the way, he's also registered his own brand
with a big certificate now at
Zander Studios, but it doesn't matter, he's also a
little brand person at 12 who wants to
make sweatshirts
amuses me so much and
every day is actually a shame without him
but I still love my husband after 23
years like the first day and
Fran is a really cool guy and I
really enjoy being with him
but I also have my girls and my  job and
you know, I used to just
do it, today I sometimes think to myself
how good it is to get a little
more out of it than just work,
but I also love my work. You
've already hinted a bit
that your media career was
super positive at the beginning  There you were,
so to speak, a puppy protector and then
everyone celebrated you as the young,
exciting person from Hamburg back then and then everything
turned around, what happened then,
so it didn't
turn properly, but first you were the
puppy, the favorite, Kleene with her
way too high a voice, they
treated me to everything and so on and then at
some point there were two
cutting points, e.g. once it was
the mirror that simply
calculated what the advertising icon
deserved. There were two sides in the
mirror that naturally had me  nobody
asked but it was a research about
my advertising contracts. Funnily enough,
I wasn't that interested at
breakfast in what number it came
out. You see, I wasn't really
interested in
it
what do we do today and
men? Every board member I met at the
time asked me about it,
not a single woman,
but that was probably already 20-30
million or something like that, no, it's
hard to say, only they can see the
old mirror
fished out the old paper collection again but
it was suddenly clear to the media makers that
our little darling with
the too high voice with the
weak dative voice who still somehow
wears dresses that are too short and somehow
always seems a bit like Olivia from
Popey has now
become an entrepreneur  and a very well-
earning entrepreneur who is really just
starting out here as a woman and then
the media dismissed this puppy protection,
this image, this image, which is also so
stupid, that's why it's
an old image, I
loved it, I've gotten along with it well
now that I'm 50 plus  I don't want to
be a stupid anymore but back then it was so
funny I loved it and flirted with it
and in my book there's a
chapter in my autobiography
that takes everything into account now I don't know
anymore I think 11th chapters or something like that
are all smart  That's
all it says, everyone was of course
stupid, but I was playing with it,
only at that time it was such a breaking point
that suddenly everyone said hey, the
little girl who is flying around here
and dancing on everyone's noses and
somehow Miss Hamburg and Miss Germany
and somehow always a new
idea came up that made it and then
the interviews changed,
more seriousness came in, I was questioned more, I was examined more, people
looked more for what was behind my facade
and how hard I
could endure things  That was also
a step, for example, and when I got my Bambi in
2002 I think or something for a
career, it was
very clear in the media world at that time
there was no influenza. At that
time there were no casting shows,
so all the ones we have today  There
were no prizes for your success either, there
was only the old hard core
of journalists who had learned from the pcke
and worked their way up
and of course I was an
outsider and then um also for
career the category was created for the
first time  forgiven because they couldn't
agree on what I would get the Bambi,
they just agreed that
I would get one and that's
how it was that from then on the media
treated me completely differently, so
it was a completely different matter
when you  I'm allowed to say that and, um,
this article that praises me to
heaven with compliments and so on. That
changed suddenly and then I
also found out that
Taft was really getting down to business and I
was often invited to
interviews  Yes, they wrote to
me that I had to come and they
tried to influence me a lot. They
tried
to find a lot of things in my private life, but
I'm very open and
very honest because my mother
always has the best wisdom
always said just tell the truth
because the truth is forever and the
lie is only for a short time yes and since
I actually always told the truth
there was never anything to look for where you
could take me to the previous places
but you have it  They tried again and again, they
tried again and again to tell me about something
in my past that
was negative, but it didn't exist and I
didn't have a corpse in the basement and so
I went my own way, but the Bambi who had
the double page in the mirror
about my earnings back then  As an advertising icon, you
suddenly turned the cute little
Miss Hamburg into an entrepreneur
in a man's world 20
years ago that was a little different
than it is today.
Looking back, of all your
activities,
the most successful thing you've done from an economic point of view are
the advertising contracts  or the television shows
or the modeling what is it?
So economically, of course, it
was the advertising contracts and
still is today, but that's how
you build a name for yourself, just like
an athlete spends his life pushing the ball
over the string  Skin and then you only get the
money when you're 20 or 25. Sometimes you have to
give up everything,
every time you have a child, a friend
has a glass of wine or champagne. You're
only in the gym as an athlete and you
have to deliver your performance
while everyone else is celebrating  You
have friends sitting in the garden and barbecuing and
then all of a sudden you get the message
that when you wear your sports brand,
what's happening on the market and then
everyone says yes, suddenly they drink a
Coke and then so much happens -
of course that's the work you do
has done before and it was the same for me. I
had to
build up a name for myself and be so strong in advertising
that the
advertising partners themselves - it was
always said by the advisors that it cannibalizes
itself - that I first have to learn the word
she can  I can't advertise three things at the same time
but I was able to do it that way but you
also have because I
saw that on TV and talked about it,
something from you is coming, so I
mean you have the advertising or the
advertising also based on
television presence in the end on your own shows
and I think that was a bit of a
lever in retrospect, or yes, I've been a lecturer since
2023, in that year we're still a
lecturer. That's new, that's a whole
new professional branch in my life. I
actually founded more than
talking GmbH  TV production and
of course if you quickly say
Modern Talking but it's just a
little joke on the
side yes it's a little joke on the
side but it's been too long it's been
25 years now I couldn't base it on that
but how great MILF yes
super in the middle of life woman means more
than talking comes from the heart with the
but the power that makes the
television because more than talking means
more than just a conversation what we
have here is more than talking that
is more than just blah blah that is more  As
a small talk, what I'm
playing here is for me men talking more
than just talking in German and I've
now placed this show on Magenta TV
man talking with Thomas Anders
sopia tomaller Simone tomaller
I still had Guido Maria Kretscher Steffen
Henzler was  So that was really fun
and Franziska von almseg was
there too and now it
's been so successful that
Magenta has extended the contract for another six seasons
and
I wrote the concept and
piloted it
with Sony Pictures back then  and then
I did that,
then Sony Pictures sold it, which was
called the neusis in between, to
Magenta and then I
became a producer and now I'm going into my
second season as a producer and that
's of course a huge partner Telekom
Magenta and all the celebrity presenters
actors all want  I actually like
working with Magenta, it's
really cool that I'm together with them
now. Now I'm going into the
second season. I'm very, very
proud of it. I'm rarely too proud
of my children, but I'm not so
quick to be proud of them all  As a
producer, I'm new to it
and
I'm currently in the process of designing a new show with Warner Brothers.
I can
tell you that because some people here
actually hear it and
yes, it's a super cool company
and we are  We really agreed and
the concept also came from me but
we are now working on it together. It
will also be a very nice story
and yes, this is a completely new
field and I also
thought in the middle of my life, wow do you really want to
now  Become a producer who is supposed to
take that seriously and
implement your concepts now, of all things, there are thousands of euros
behind it, producing pilots,
placing it and so on, and now
I've already said that with Magenta, of course,
my successful format is more than
talking  Production company also
called that and I'm now looking forward to the
next story okay so that
means moving image Accompany you even
further and absolutely that's my
biggest wish and my biggest dream
is of course a
kind of late night
show at some point in the future  talking to people more than
talking inviting people so the German
Opera Grandpa that and that's my
heart and soul that's my thing and that's what
I'm working towards why you've never
done law I would have thought so
somehow now I've heard
a little bit about your career  I was thinking about the fact
that you actually appeared in all the
different shows, I mean, well, there were some,
your
ex-husband was also on the jury, but you also had
different jury tasks. You never
did them, yes, I think  I'm too
versatile to be put on a jury,
so to speak. I was on the
jury twice, once at Pool Champions,
it was about swimming and
there was Franziska von almsig,
I still remember we
sat on the jury together, that was
one  very nice show, it was
actually fun but I think
the bit of a problem was that
most of it took place underwater,
of course there were underwater cameras there
M, the presentation was gigantic
but for the viewer there were
too many underwater images then I sat in
front of it  Many years ago there was
a kind of super talent on the jury with DJ Bobo and
Elten, we also judged talent,
but that was a long time ago and it
was really a lot of fun, but it was also very time-consuming, but
otherwise you left out a lot of things
For example, even
then, I don't think you ever danced, so
you would have thought okay, what else could Verona have done, dance show, there would have been more,
but at some point you didn't do anything, so
I think I did everything except
for Let dan  took part because that's
the good thing about midlife, I know what I
can do, what I can't do, I don't consider myself
a great dancer, I
can definitely cha chaa and
I also did a waltz with Guido
Maria Kretschm on my show Moden
Talking  We danced the waltz
but
I don't know, I wasn't that
convinced I became Playbo, you did
n't do Playboy, no, I didn't do Playboy either,
but you didn't either,
no one asked me yet, oh well,
I can change that when I'm out of here
I can,
no, yes, I think it was always
expected that I would take off my clothes, that I did
n't want to take off my clothes. If I had
chosen a completely different career now, I'm now a
lawyer or something, then maybe I would have
done it, but I just found it too, yes
Trivial this question,
all the photographers always wanted to
undress me and everyone was always
behind me. Take off your clothes. Take off your clothes
then I was with Germany. Take off your clothes
then I was with this party. Take off your clothes then
I was
divorced then take your clothes off  I have a
peep, oh Verona's world, take
off your clothes. What was offered to DAF if you
had taken off your clothes at the maximum, so
of course the prices rose from year to
year and I don't want to be alarmed and
the poor pleb is now going to have
a heart attack, but the truth remains
The truth is that we were
already at seven figures with sponsors' ideas for
moving out. I think
only Kathar has managed it so far, but otherwise it
wasn't enough. No, that had
nothing to do with it. I could have put the money to good
use. I didn't start with anything
I come from a
three-story high-rise building and only had
my ideas without a degree if
you go back in time and if I had been
offered €250,000 back then,
that would have changed my whole life,
that would have secured me, that was more
than you can imagine  Look,
if you have nothing, nothing just you and
your ideas, then 250,000 for
Playboy is actually a compliment because
Playboy has been a compliment in Germany for so long,
you would
say that, of course, we Germans are open
to everything but it is  Playboy is still as
relevant as it was back then. I don't know if
it's that relevant. I don't think so
anymore because of course
everything has changed thanks to social media and
nudity is viewed completely differently,
but Playboy has been around for
decades, even back then  It was like
an accolade for
celebrities because celebrities
only went topless. The pictures were
taken in the Caribbean, which used to
be unattainable. People didn't know about image retouching.
You always looked like a
million people and you already have these pictures in black and white
in your living room today  which is
almost something from our parents who
had pictures in the 70s, no one comes
in anymore and shouts and says ah, that
's your wife when it's from a good
photographer and the whole living room
is fashionable and then she's lying
across the beach  So I'm looking at
a carpet like this with an iron like this, but it's
so cool, then you're really talking
about art and you can
move into the plebo from on the
fox carpet in front of the fireplace with the ice cream in your
hand to  to a picture of Helmut
Newton or Karl Lagerfeld photographed in black and white
in Paris is of course
something else and Karl Lagerfeld was
my friend who made my wedding dress
and if I had taken the first Playboy
pictures with him then I would be
in the museum today, so I was  I'm already
smart enough to realize that I do
n't let the average photographer
take Playboy photos with me, but
someone
who has a name like that would have had to come along so that it does
n't become art at that moment, but
no, they have too much on my T-shirt
pulled then I became stubborn like that T-shirt
stays on okay okay wait until you
've reached the middle of your life so there's a
second half of life whether it always
stays that way. There are also recent
examples of
people in their older years who still
do that. Let's see, I'm  I'm curious, yes,
that's
really not an issue for me  I
'll be
lying on the bed in Malibu with Fran hand
in hand and in the newspaper we'll see
the advertising icon with the dative weakness and
her dear husband Fran the entrepreneur
have happily fallen asleep hand in hand
that's the end of me so it'll
still take a while but we've all got it  an
end and that will be in Malibu and fr
and I are the same age why should
n't we die at the same time and then that
's fine, yes that's nice
or you have to think about it but
you're not in midlife but just wait and see
That's a certain
logic because there's no other way,
no, I don't want to plan my death,
but I'm going to move to Malibu in the
next 10 years, don't think about it, it's
exactly the same, I love the beaches, I
love the food, I love them  Palm trees, I
love the weather, I love the flip-flop
and jeans to walk there and
then you have the H houses are
made of wood, they somehow have
a certain look that
just wants to come to me, you can say yes even when
you paint a picture  That's how it
came out of me and Malibu somehow wants to get into
me, into my heart, my soul,
I think it's nice to live there and
since no one has managed not to
die yet, you can
be honest, that's how I see the end of my life  I
have to laugh myself now as I come to the
topic, but that's just
the way you think about whether you
want to let your last breath out to your listeners here in front of the microphone or
with your beloved wife. I don't know
which city do you love?  Well, what do
you care about? Well, I've
never been to Malibu before, but
some people have more of a desire like that,
I don't know. That's not
for me at all. I freeze to death. I want to
be burned in Holland anyway
you pick it up after a month
and it feels like
it's made of plastic, but it's made of
pressed paper and if you
throw it somewhere it decomposes
and the trend is moving away from the
cemetery. I want mine  Please don't let children
scatter me on some kind of
meadow on the beach into the water
where the sun is always shining and that they
go for a walk and think that there's
mom's aura somewhere here, I
prefer that to sitting on that big
marble stone, so that's no
I think to get rid of two more trends:
firstly, people will
no longer allow themselves to be buried like this, the trend
is to have them
scattered in places that they
love without and in themselves and secondly, more and
more women are letting themselves be buried at the age of 30
remove the ovary, which is a very
small mini operation, to freeze it in
order to be able to become an older mother, okay,
this is the brand new Franzis, how
surprised are you, so a
small vacuum cleaner comes along, then the whole thing is
frozen and the quality of this
age is the same  given but when you
're in your middle age 45 48 you
look like a million anyway you're in a
good mood you've just earned good money you're
meeting the man of your life
and it's going to be difficult to have a child
is annoying while
men naturally do it all year round
I almost had a gag to
make it through most of your life but you also have to fall in
love and meet a great man
and if you don't meet him at 30
and not at 35 and at
45 yes and that's something now
I believe that the youth will soon  I'll
always say it's clear tomorrow I have
my appointment and that's how it will
be with the funeral, it won't
be the same anymore with this big stone that
everything is a bit
gloomy so what an end in the truest
sense of the word you can this
conversation  no different no better
binding than with this yes with
this predictions from you the forecasts
thank you very much for being there that
you told a little bit so a
little bit is good a journey through
marketing the last 20 25 years vi 30
years man  I also really see how much
this communication week
has changed, but yes, you've
really managed to do that for a long time now.
Congratulations, thank you
very much. Yes, I would also like to thank you for
the nice conversation and, as I said,
that was exactly what Mod Talking was, thank you for that
very much ciao ciao ciao
[music]
ciao